[Musique]
rassemblez-vous autour des enfants
la terre a été détruite par une grande guerre
j'étais programmé pour vous protéger
et maintenant on recommence est-ce
que quelqu'un connaît l'histoire des trois
petits cochons
le premier petit cochon a construit une maison
en paille
le deuxième  un petit cochon a rempli une maison avec des
bâtons
mais le troisième petit cochon a construit une
maison en pierre
un jour
un grand méchant loup est arrivé et a dit
petit cochon rose, laisse-moi entrer ou je vais
souffler
et je soufflerai à côté d'eux et  je vais faire exploser ta
maison dans
un grand méchant loup, elle parlait de sa
mère,
c'est elle